michael lorenzon that start was against
the pittsburgh pirates on tuesday
lorenzo coming out of the bullpen
getting a start for the first time since
2018. now the former red edwin
incarnation
boy that's a nice job by michael
lorenzen two-stranded dylan cease last
time out against the twins he only gave
up the one earned run but five walks
that's been one of the problems this
year he did get the 99 pitches however
the castillanos two and two struck him
out of fastball at 97. two hard throwers
on the ballot today now the base is
empty joey votto to the plate
and a ground ball to the right side
it'll be fielded there by abraham he'll
take the bag himself inning over base is
loaded galveston first goodwin at second
mustache is a third for barnard
he goes after the first pitch and
abreu's on the case that is it so
barnhart swinging first ball after all
those walks and hit batters and he is
out and so are the reds here in the
second april has one steal
in his only attempt
[Music]
and a throw down
got him
how about you tucker barnhart
out at second great job by barnhart
and leaves abreu at the plate as the
fourth walk surrendered by dylan cease
second of the inning juarez
swinging a miss about that back-to-back
breaking pitches
after walking a couple that is the fifth
strikeout now for dylan cease
two balls two strikes two out two on
[Applause]
right side madrigal with a high throw
jose's got it little heartbeat moment
right there 17 hits for jimenez on the
first pitch of an ab
tip into the mid of barnard 98 on the
heater one out batter edwin incarnation
check swing appeal and run him up and
chad whitson back-to-back punch-outs for
michael
two-hour batter james mccann
struck him out three straight punch outs
for lorenzo major chance for the reds
back to back to back walks faces juiced
and nobody out
bring out the prilosec to barnhart
on the ground
and they'll get the out at second base
and that's it the reds scratch across
the first run
it's an rbi ground down for tucker
barnhart and it will be arastides
aquino broken bat
and the play will be to first and the
reds score another two nothing
cincinnati bases are loaded again let's
score two in the inning looking for more
big pitch and it's inside and
detweilers walked in a run if you're
thinking about the reds you're thinking
we've got 10 walks
in the first three and two-thirds
innings and we're only winning
three-nothing why isn't it seven to
nothing right now because they don't
have any hits and here's mustaches
ground ball that'll get through
this will score castellanos here comes
vado to the play it's a big two out two
rbi hit by mike mustakis and it's
five-nothing reds
michael lorenzen's been given a
five-nothing lead a dangerous situation
here first and third one out tim
anderson at the play
struck him out oh wow got him to chase
eight of them for lorenzo and that's a
good outing there by michael lorenzen if
indeed it is over you got to pry the
ball for michael lorenzen and he finally
gives it up lucas sims will come in he
inherits a couple of men on two outs
here nick madrigal trying to salvage the
inning for the socks 2-2
[Applause]
nick has to throw his bat at that ball
slow roller he's safe he beat it out
nikki two strikes gets after it again
it's five to one bravo a single and a
wonk
jose rips at left field side down the
line it goes aquino's got to go get it
one run is home madrigal scores
on madrigal the third sanchez scores it
is five to two on abreu's rbi doubles
the red sketch break now they've got a
runner at second base for the punisher
in the air the punisher is back
a no doubter in fact the outfielders
didn't even give chase they just watched
it fly
there's that flex
7-2 reds
edwin three strikeouts today sox have 13
strikeouts
edwin hits this ball very well to right
field and gone
seven to three
one better late i knew the home run
thing was gone but just a question to
win and that line drive rocket
makes it a four run game so the parrot
although he's probably freezing makes an
appearance
and edwin
372 feet of line drive home run
after sweeping the pirates that on the
heels of taking two out of three in
saint louis and the white sox coming to
town at the time the best record in the
american league a high-powered offense
everyone wondered how would they do
against this big american league team
one out away from doing very nicely
and that will do it
the reds win this one seven to three
it's their third straight series win
they've won seven of eight
eight of ten
and are back to the 500 mark